okay but to understand
the true disgrace that joe biden is you
have to actually follow the timeline of
what he has been saying for months and
all the lies his administration has been
telling because the lies never stopped
at any point at any point
and he's going to continue to lie when
he says i'm getting americans out i'm
getting all the afghan allies out we're
going to perform missions we're going to
go get do you believe a word that comes
out of his drooling mouth
do you believe a word that comes from
this man if you do you are a fool
because we're about to play an entire
timeline of the stuff that joe biden has
said
since april when he announced we were
pulling out he has not said a true thing
this entire way so let's begin
this begins april 14th this is when joe
biden announced that we were leaving
here's how he described the operation
that was going to lead to our exit in
afghanistan
we'll not conduct a hasty rush to the
exit
we'll do it we'll do it responsibly
deliberately and safely
and we will do it in full coordination
with our allies and partners who now
have more forces in afghanistan than we
do
and the taliban should know that if they
attack us as we draw down
we will defend ourselves and our
partners with all the tools at our
disposal oh really
um so yeah um not a word of that was
true responsibly in coordination with
our allies our allies think we're a
bunch of idiots because the president is
so he betrayed our allies he betrayed
the afghans
we didn't do this responsibly we didn't
do this deliberately
so that was just a lie okay fast forward
to july this of course his most famous
lie when he says this isn't going to be
anything like the fall of saigon he's
right it's way worse than the fall of
saigon do you see any parallels between
this withdrawal and what happened in
vietnam with some people feeling
whatsoever zero what you had is you had
entire brigades breaking through the
gates of our embassy
six if i'm not mistaken the taliban is
not the south of the north vietnamese
army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan it is not at all comfortable
not comfortable
i mean that's good to know it's not
comfortable um so that was july 8th
kidman that was a lie everybody knew
that was a lie
and there's a notion that it was like a
giant shock it's just not true it wasn't
a giant child okay so he was lying on
april 14th when he said that this would
be a a considered move and the taliban
wouldn't take over the country and all
that then on july 8th he said that
they're not like the viet cong and this
wouldn't be like saigon so he was lying
then now fast forward to the last week
and a half or so so today is august 27th
so all of this stuff that we are about
to examine is from the last 11 days the
number of lies this president and his
administration have told in the last 11
days boggles the mind but they think
that you are a fool and they think that
you don't follow this stuff and so they
assume that they'll be able to get away
with this
the most humiliating foreign policy
debacle of my lifetime bar none
okay so let's fast forward to august
16th
joe biden says the buck stops with him
and the reason that we are leaving is
because we can't take more casualties
thousands of more casualties
again this was a lie when he said it we
had taken zero american casualties in
combat since february of 2020 at the
moment that he said this on august 16th
he said the buck stops with him this is
designed to prevent american casualties
i noticed a few american casualties
yesterday
i am president of the united states of
america
and the buck stops with me
i'm deeply saddened by the facts we now
face
but i do not regret my decision to end
america's war fighting in afghanistan
and maintain a laser focus on our
counter-terrorism missions there and
other parts of the world i cannot and
will not ask our troops to fight
on endlessly another in another
country's civil war
taking casualties
suffering life-shattering injuries
leaving families broken by grief and
loss
this is not in our national security
interest okay keeping 2 500 troops there
with zero combat casualties since
february was not in our national
security interest withdrawing them so
that 13 of them could be murdered at the
hands of isis k that was definitely our
national interest that was august 16th
fast forward two days joe biden has
watched as withdrawal has turned into a
debacle already by this point we've
already seen the video of afghans
falling from the bottom of planes trying
to escape the clutches of the taliban he
does an interview with george
stephanopoulos on august 18th and um he
says nobody has died at knock on wood
pathetic
still a lot of pandemonium outside the
airport well there is but look
but no one's being killed right now god
forgive me for if i'm wrong about that
forbid i mean if i'm wrong about that
knows me
by the way by the point he said that
people had already been killed outside
the air like seven people had already
died during the evacuation by that point
now the new death toll as of this moment
has now stretched
all the way up to
something like 170 people are dead 170
including the 13 us service members and
18 more wounded
okay then that same interview joe biden
says we're not going to leave americans
or american allies behind
a
lie all troops are supposed to be out by
august 31st
even if americans and our afghan allies
are still trying to get out they're
going to leave
we're going to do everything in our
power to get all americans out and our
allies out um nope
nope so he's lying then okay fast
forward two days after that now we're
only six days we're now seven days ago
this is august 20th joe biden again
reiterates we are not going to leave
americans behind he was lying
let me be clear
any american who wants to come home
we will get you home
nope
wrong
lie
hey also that same presser he says you
know the good news is al qaeda is not in
afghanistan uh there's only one problem
everyone knew al-qaeda was in
afghanistan not only is al qaeda in
afghanistan you know the people who are
actually handling the the security
around the airport for the taliban our
trusted partners over here you know who
it is it's the so-called haqqani network
what is the haqqani network it's an al
qaeda offshoot
not only is al qaeda in afghanistan
they're handling the security at the
airport joe biden is trusting this man
is a disgrace and a liar
let's put this thing in perspective here
what interest do we have in afghanistan
at this point with al qaeda gone
we went to afghanistan for the express
purpose of getting rid of al qaeda in
afghanistan as well as as well as
getting osama bin laden and we did
oh did we al-qaeda is still in
afghanistan and by the way so is isis
and the people we hand the country back
to are the exact same people who harbor
those people again it boggles the mind
that we are supposed to like he thinks
you are such a
that that we handed the same country
back to the same people who harbored bin
laden and al qaeda and we're supposed to
now treat them as reasonable peace
partners as they go around shooting
people in the head they're dragging
people out of their homes and shooting
them in the head if they worked with the
americans
and joe biden says don't worry there
won't be any uptick in terror while the
terrorists are handling the security
around the airport that's how stupid he
thinks you are
okay that same press conference august
20th joe biden says don't worry any
attack on our forces will be met with a
swift and forceful response well um the
bombing happened
24 hours ago we have seen no swift
response we have seen no forceful
response we have seen no response from
the presidents of the united states
we made clear to the taliban that any
attack
any attack on our forces or disruption
of our operations at the airport will be
met with swift and forceful response
oh well that's um well yeah clearly
cause he's lying okay fast forward a
couple days after that now joe biden has
asked a question about isis and he does
what he does best he runs away because
he's a damned coward
that americans face now bye catch you
later
by the way that same day he said that we
had expanded the airport safe zone
right he said this to the american
people august 22nd this is five days ago
and four days before isis just blew
everybody up
we have uh constantly uh
how can i say it
increased
rational access to the airport
where more folk can get there more
safely it's still a dangerous operation
but i don't want to go into the detail
of how we're doing that i think you're
going to see they're going to get out
number two we have made a number of
changes including extended
access around the airport and the safe
zone
oh really it seemed like that that
seemed like a super safe zone right
outside the airport by all available
metrics it was super safe
okay then same day he says do we trust
the taliban i don't trust anyone i'm
just giving them lists of american
allies they can kill them
i don't trust anybody including you i
love you but you know there's not a lot
of people i trust there's not a lot of
people i trust like i don't trust you
the same way i don't trust the talent
[Music]
hey then
his press secretary jensachi who is his
night nurse that's his actual night
nurse joe biden comes out he craps the
bed and it's jen saki's job to clean it
up
shensaki says august 23rd remember this
is four days ago
three days before what just happened at
the airport in terms of the giant isis
attack
gensake insisted no americans are
stranded it's all your imagination there
are no americans stranded this lying
dishonest pathetic administration here's
jinsaki
does the person have a sense that most
of the criticism is not of leaving
afghanistan it's the way that he has
ordered it to happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home we are in touch
with them via phone via text via email
via any way that we can possibly reach
americans to get them home if they want
to return home there are no american
stranded is the white house's official
position on what's happening in
afghanistan i'm just calling you out for
saying that we are stranding americans
in afghanistan when i set when we have
been very clear that we are not leaving
americans who want to return home who
want to return home is always their key
word there because the idea is that
we're going to blame the people who
remain also we are leaving them behind
clearly joe biden said it last night
don't worry we'll figure out after we're
out of there
have no resources on the ground have
zero leverage because we ain't going
back in then we'll figure out how to get
them out
so she was lying then
next day she just again this was
literally two days now before the isis
attack she says um this is a massive
success i don't think you guys are
giving us credit for what a massive
success it is for us to load the
lifeboats with people after we blew a
hole under the water line of the titanic
after we dynamited this boat i don't
think you're giving us enough credit for
how many people we've offloaded onto the
lifeboats
i would say that this is now on track
peter to be the largest airlift in u.s
history uh so and that is uh
bringing american citizens out it is
bringing our afghan partners out it is
bringing allies out uh so no i would not
say that is anything but a success it's
she won't say it's anything but a
success
there's only one word you can use for
what we've been seeing according to the
bite administration two days ago
and that's success
just success
so i leave it to you
is this administration
competent
capable
are they acting in the best interests of
america's future or the american people
or indeed in the interest of the
american service members
or
is this an administration a clown car
careening out of control with a senile
person at the head of it occasionally
bloviating a particularly stupid idea
and everybody rushing to fill the gap
you tell me
there are a lot of dead bodies that tell
the story in kabul today
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier
that is just science
[Music]